foreign
good afternoon and welcome to today's
Richard M karp distinguished lecture
my name is Sandy Irani I'm the associate
director of the Simon's Institute and
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
Simons which is probably absolutely no
one here but anyway
um we are the uh
world's leading venue for collaborative
research and theoretical computer
science established in 2012 with the
generous Grant from the Simons
Foundation
we bring together the world's leading
researchers and the theory of computing
and related fields
so we established this particular
lecture series The Richard and carp disc
distinguished lecture series to
celebrate the role of Simon's founding
director dick karp in establishing the
field of theoretical computer science
formulating at Central problems and a
stunning array of results
um the series features Visionary leaders
such as we have today in the field of
theoretical computer science and is
geared towards a broad scientific
audience so we're very grateful to all
the people who have contributed to this
fund and made the talk series possible
and I'm delighted today to welcome our
speaker Aaron sidford who probably needs
no introduction in this group
um Aaron received his PhD in eecs at MIT
and is now and I had to update this I
was going to say he was an assistant
professor but as of Friday he's an
associate professor congratulations
Aaron in the department of management
science and engineering and CS at
Stanford
and um his research interests are very
much aligned with the topic of the
current program in data structures
optimization graph Theory numerical
linear algebra data structures and he's
really been a major player in the
advancement of the field which as you
know has led to some really stunning
breakthrough results giving nearly
optimal algorithms for many of the
foundational problems in our field so
um and also uh as you probably know
Aaron's done just a huge amount of work
in organizing this program and has put a
lot of thought into what you can hope to
accomplish this semester and how to
structure this program to be as
productive as possible so it's
especially apt to have him giving this
talk at the beginning of the semester
sort of giving an overview of the field
and the title of today's talk is aptly
titled an introduction to data
structures and optimization for fast
algorithms so please join me in
welcoming Aaron
foreign
thank you very much for that generous
introduction and thank you for inviting
me and thank you to The Institute for
everything and helping to put together
this quarter um it is a real semester
this is a it's a real pleasure to be uh
presenting here today I'm delighted to
be giving this introduction to data
structures and optimization for fast
algorithms and yes this is the first
talk I am giving as a 10-year faculty so
thank you it is quite an honor to be
doing that here so thank you so the plan
for this talk
um the focus of the talk and the main
goal um is to give an introduction and a
broad motivation for this program
happening this quarter on data
structures and optimization for fast
algorithms my main goal and plan for the
talk is to try to convey some of the
main themes and reasons for excitement
and motivations and everything
underlying this program happening at the
Institute this quarter
um so I'm going to start with a kind of
broad infra introduction to the program
and the area and this line of work on
getting fast algorithms for a number of
problems and after this uh introduction
kind of broadly to the area I'm going to
spend a bit more time going a little
more in depth on what I think are some
illustrative examples that I think
really well highlight some of the major
themes running through the program so
I'll start when this will probably be
the most substantive part of the talk
I'll go a bit in depth on different from
certain aspects of linear programming
that I think well articulate some of the
themes of the program I'll then talk a
little bit about the dynamic matching
problem about bipartite matching and
dynamic algorithms for for it this will
highlight some other major themes on the
program and this seemed like a pretty uh
appropriate thing to be presenting in a
Richard carp lecture series
um and then I said I have time at the
end I'll talk a little bit about more
about some other examples I'm
particularly excited to be presenting
today both to tell even if you're not
participating in any of these programs
or not participating anything at the
Institute to kind of tell you about the
excitement that underlies this program
and what maybe you can look for in the
future and some results you can look for
I'm also really grateful for the
institute for getting to present today
in particular because we had our boot
camp last week and we gave tutorials on
the different aspects of the program and
I guess this is the first slightly more
technical talk kind of at the
intersection of all the areas so I
thought this also might be nice uh you
know for the excitement of everyone in
the program
um so that's my motivation I just want
to give a quick disclaimer though I'm
very motivated by the major themes in
the program and I'll touch upon the
major themes of this program this is a
slightly more focused technical talk
um I'm definitely going to be a bit
biased and talk a bit about my own work
and highlight some examples that I'm a
bit more familiar with and I've worked
with so I don't want to give the
impression that this is like the
complete comprehensive list of
everything in uh guiding the program
this is definitely going to be a little
bit of a biased tour
um and I just want to give again a quick
plug to check out the program all the
work uh videos from our boot camp last
week are out so if you're excited about
any of the topics you can check out the
boot camp videos and I think I managed
to find a pointer to every bootcamp talk
scattered out throughout this talk so
we'll do that
all right so what's the motivating this
program and this talk and what are we
going to be talking about today
um the key motivation is a number of
advances in algorithm design a number of
advances that have happened over the
last decade maybe a little more I'm
getting provably efficient algorithms
for solving a wide range of foundational
problems so for a pretty diverse set I
think of like foundational problems and
theoretical computer science like
analyzing Markov chains Computing vertex
connectivity of a graph Computing gum
rehoo trees many many problems over the
last decade there's been some major
progress on getting run times and
algorithmic results for these problems
that overcome a number of decades-old
barriers a number of cases have led to
not just faster algorithms or improved
results or more efficient ways of
solving these problems but actually ways
of solving these problems in nearly
linear time which is almost in your time
which is almost optimal for some of
these problems so this has been the holy
grail and the design of you know faster
algorithms or some of these problems for
a number of them now be you know they've
long been known to be polynomial time
solvable we actually know the optimal
asymptotic complexity up to some some
factors that I don't know maybe people
will work on improving in this program
um and what I find particularly striking
about this work Beyond just the
applications Beyond just the faster uh
run times I've been achieved is like the
wide range of algorithmic tools that
have gone into use in order to obtain
them these results have an interesting
combination of advances in using
optimization methods things that maybe
you think of as being used for
continuous optimization like gradient
descent methods or interior Point
methods they use a variety of data
structures to decompose the problem in a
way that's compatible with how the
optimization methods work and they also
use a variety of random sampling and
sketching techniques that perhaps you
might think of as motivated by very
massive scale data analysis to speed up
the implementation and the solution and
solving these problems
um and this is just a taste um and I
think what's interesting about these
examples is the surprising ways that
these different tools and techniques and
areas of research have kind of come
together and played off each other in
interesting ways to get these results
and in getting a number of these
advances there's a highlighted sort of
new connections or new problems you'd
want to solve in each of these areas
um you know by the ultimate goal perhaps
of solving some of these problems more
efficiently so I want to tell you about
like one sort of broad template that I
think you know has arisen for like
showing how you can combine these tools
and techniques together to get certain
results so to motivate like one common
template that's a common theme through
the program and number of these results
let's think of a natural setting you
know it's kind of when I motivated where
you want to solve some difficult
algorithmic or optimization problem you
want to solve a linear system you want
to compute a maximum flow like the
maximum number of disto and paths in a
graph you want to minimize a convex
function something like this we don't
want to design efficient method for
solving this difficult problem
well a natural thing you might do you
know is try to apply any of the many
different types of optimization methods
that have been designed for solving
these problems or a broad class of
problems like you could take gradient
descent methods that locally try to make
progress on minimizing the function or
interior Point methods that work for
linear programs which you can cast you
know say maximum flow as and if you
think of what these optimization methods
do when you apply them to these problems
you know these optimization methods they
often follow some iterative framework
they take some step getting some
information about the problem use it to
make some progress take another step use
that to incorporate that information to
take another step and keep repeating
until ultimately they solve the problem
and if you think about this what this
means is these optimization methods they
oh you can think of them as reducing
something these difficult optimization
problems you know to Computing whatever
is information and doing whatever local
operation is needed you know to get
every step of the optimization method to
work and this often means these
optimization methods reduce these
difficult problems to much simpler
things like multiply a matrix with a
vector in the case of solving linear
system or find a good path in a graph
for the case of Maximum flow
and if you try then to follow this
approach to get faster algorithms for
solving these problems you know a
natural thing you might do is you know
try to design optimization methods that
take fewer iterations they don't require
as many steps of solving the simple
problem and somehow the maybe the sub
problems you have to solve you know uh
are more efficient to implement it's a
simpler type of path to compute or the
Matrix you're doing a matrix Vector with
has more structure
and this works fine but in some cases
and I'll talk about some examples later
there are cases where you know after you
know Decades of effort you know we
haven't figured out ways to solve get
the optimization method to take few
iterations There's real bottlenecks and
barriers in some cases they're even
lower bounds saying in the worst case
you know if all your optimization method
does is get this certain piece of
information about your function it might
take a certain number of iterations
so how can you improve this in these
cases if we can't get you know just
decrease the number of iterations of the
optimization method or there's limits in
the sub problems we're solving
well there's one natural thing you might
do if you wanted to try to you know use
this template to solve the problems more
efficiently what you could do is maybe
instead of just thinking about this
entire framework in terms of how many
sub problems do I solve and how hard is
it to solve each sub-problem you could
ask the joint question of how hard is it
to solve the sequence of sub problems if
you look at you know the sequence of
Matrix vectors you need to compute the
sequence is a paths you can you hope to
compute you might hope that this overall
set of iterates has some sort of joint
structure that maybe the amortized cost
of implementing all the iterations is
much cheaper right and with this you
know you so in other words you could
think that the optimization method is
generating the sequence of problems you
need to solve and maybe you can get a
faster runtime by solving the dynamic
problem of being able to maintain
solutions to those sub problems
all right
so that's a broad idea and I want to
quickly point out or immediately point
out this is not actually a new idea this
is a very old classic idea to get faster
algorithmic results you know even if we
go back to the first proof of an
interior Point method solving linear
programs in polynomial time you know due
to Karma car and not in stock in 1984.
um even then the method both provided an
optimization method and looked at the
Shared structure of the the steps of
that method was a sequence of linear
systems you would have to solve and by
leveraging the shared structure of those
linear systems came up with faster
runtimes you know this has also been
done in Max flow if you think of their
use of Link cut trees and implementing
the sub problems when you run
um a certain iterative methods to solve
Max flow
um and this was also you know I haven't
I'm not quite comfortable yet with the
idea of citing my own to work as old but
someone else uh told me this recently so
I thought it was fair game
it's like solving laplacian systems
solving a certain class of linear
systems associated with graphs that's
had a lot of applications
um and there were certain algorithms
that took a number of simple iterative
steps and used data structures to make
you know speed up the cost per every
iteration if you want more about that
application and the many implications it
has for our program you can see
sushant's nice talk from the workshop
last week
all right so we're trying to solve these
problems faster and this template we're
following is a rather old classic one
what's new and what's motivating this
program well I think there's a few
things where some of the recent work has
maybe gone a little further than this
classic template and I think one
interesting striking way in which this
has happened is in this recent work uses
a variety of different sketching and
sampling techniques to solve these data
structure problems they take an entire
sketch of the input they use certain
samplings of the input and they kind of
use this to speed up the cost of getting
you know the information the
optimization method needs in every
iteration this immediately creates in a
number of these settings an issue where
you want to use some sort of random
sampling and sketch to speed up the
iterations but you're going to use the
output of this sampling process you know
to inform the next step that the
optimization takes so you immediately
have this dependence that whatever
Randomness you use in your sketching
might show up again in the next input
um this this uh feature that these these
uh input to the data structure chosen
may be adversarially or adaptive to what
you do in solving the data structure
creates a whole host of issues that a
number of these results needs to
overcome to get uh faster runtimes
um I think there's also an interesting
theme throwing through this going
through this work and really how they
use different continuous optimization
methods to solve these problems and how
there's been work on sort of this joint
design of what is the continuous
optimization method how does that impact
the type of data structure problem we
want to solve and can you find a
configuration of this where you can
actually use sampling to get the
information you need to make the
iterations fast enough
and and lastly I think it's been
exciting a number of these cases it's
not just led to some improvement but
almost linear or near optimal run times
for solving a variety of these problems
um so it shows for very large instances
in a number of cases you can solve them
almost optimally
um and I think this this broad template
right of sort of using this combination
of the optimization methods with data
structures and sketching to make them
work you know it's led to a number of
um exciting results
um as you may have heard led to the
recently the first almost linear time
algorithm for solving Max flow it's led
to nearly linear time algorithms for
solving linear programs in certain
regimes and more broadly than this than
just these like algorithmic results I
think it's highlighted a number of
really interesting sort of connections
between them like this is motivated
solving some data twists on classic data
structure problems
um that maybe hadn't been considered
before that are well motivated by this
or it's informed that you might want to
design optimization methods with
different properties than you might just
think of if you're only in analyzing in
terms of how many iterations and what's
the cost per iteration so it's I think
created a whole host of new impactful
problems to solve in all of these areas
and new connections
in the second part of the talk I'll talk
a bit more about linear programming
which I think is one canonical classical
optimization problem and I'll kind of
highlight where these pieces come from
and maybe where some of the you know
surprising magic happens to actually
solve this in your linear time in some
settings
um but this is just one template or just
one way that these areas have been you
know connected towards
um you know have been connected towards
uh you know getting number of these
algorithmic advances and another theme
running through the program is to
explore the kind of interesting
different robust ways these different
areas interact so here's another pathway
or another way in which these areas have
been connected so you can imagine our
starting point is not that we want to
solve our static problem like solve a
linear program
um you know solve maximum flow but our
starting point is we really want to
solve a dynamic problem we really have
some Dynamic changing data right we want
to maintain some important properties of
that data as it changes over time
you can ask you know how can we use all
of this Machinery that's been developed
for solving these static problems can we
somehow apply them in nice canonical
ways to solve these Dynamic problems you
know the picture I had on the previous
slide was using you know optimization
methods to reduce these static problems
to Dynamic problems can we go in the
other direction
um and there has been work on doing this
that you can apply optimization methods
to sometimes break down solving you know
difficult uh Dynamic optimization
problems
into solving a certain sequence of
static optimization problems and I'll
show one example where you can do this
in a fairly Black Box way where you can
separate you know how you solve the sub
problem to get the dynamic problem from
you know all the structure of the
dynamic problem and the dynamicness of
the problem so you can actually use in
some cases optimization Theory to go
from Dynamic problems to static problems
the case I'll show you so in the third
part I'll talk about an example of this
of dynamic matching and in that example
it'll be interesting because the final
result I'll tell you will actually use
these recent advances in solving Max
flow in almost linear time so it means
the way these sub problems are solved is
also by using the whole connection
between reducing Dynamic to stat
aesthetic to Dynamic and using sketching
underneath it so you can see how the
cycle grows
so that's one pathway the goal of the
program is to explore all these rich
connections between these areas and the
pursuit of fast algorithms so the focus
of the program is trying to you know
design more efficient algorithms looking
for new tools and Frameworks and robust
connections between them and kind of
advancing each area and exploring the
connections between them
um
case anyone's curious and I want to give
a quick thank you to all my
co-organizers for boot camp last week
and all these workshops coming up so
they'll be a workshop focused on each of
these particular areas obviously with
some focus on the interplay and
connection between all of them
um and if you want more information
about any of this the boot camp videos I
think are already out from last week
so that's the plan for the talk
um what I want to do now is talk through
linear programming which I think about
some runtimes for linear programming
which I think is sort of a prototypical
example of this sort of like broad
Paradigm for solving certain sorts of
algorithmic problems but I'll take a
quick second for questions if anyone
wants
it's been a few months I guess I'm still
in teaching everyone's okay with the
plan great
all right
good so let's talk a bit a little bit
about linear programming I'm going to
use this as one illustrative example I
think of the surprising or interesting
connections between some of these areas
to really like overcome some inherent
barriers towards getting fast algorithms
all right so we'll focus on linear
programming
for this next part of the talk our focus
is going to be solving a linear program
there's a variety of canonical ways of
writing a linear program or Primal and
dual form I'll do my best I hope I did
my best to commit to this being the
notation I'll use for the rest of the
talk we have some uh n by D Matrix a and
we can look at the associated linear
program in Primal form so this is like
minimizing some the cost of some
non-negative Vector substantial linear
constraints or this the Dual which is
maximizing some linear cost function
subject to some linear inequality
constraints we have uh
um that's the problem this is a
foundational problem that's been studied
for decades and continuous and
combinatorial optimization with many
results many implications of just
looking at the structure of this
problems and The Duality and what it can
say about a variety of problems and it's
also been a very general problem where
techniques for solving this General
problem have had implication for solving
different sorts of special cases so for
a number of problems like maximum flow
solving Markov decision processes L1
regression in some regime the fastest
algorithms we have in some sense use
tools for solving this debatably more
General problem of linear programming
all right just to make sure everyone has
a good geometric picture before I start
talking about run times and the state of
the art and some of the obstacles I'm
going to highlight how we can overcome
let's just do a quick picture for what
these linear programs look like I
usually find it easier to draw linear
programs in the Dual so I'll do that so
again we have this n by D cos Matrix a
our variables y live in Rd we have a d
dimensional cost vector and the C an
n-dimensional constraint Vector you know
if we let A1 through a n denote the rows
of our Matrix and C1 through C end note
the entries of C then the constraints
that a y is larger than C every row of a
induces the constraint that y must lie
on one side of a half space
the feasible region we're then
optimizing over in this linear program
is the intersection of these n different
half spaces if we take the intersection
of these n half spaces we get a convex
polygon known as a polytope and if we
make our cost Vector pointed straight
down then maximizing the cost is trying
to find the bottom of this polytope
all right so this problem is trying to
find the bottom of this large High
dimensional context body
that's why I pointed downward
yeah it was upward
yeah
but I guess we can debate the meaning of
the vector so let's let's use the
meaning that makes the picture right
great question okay so there's a number
of standard methods for solving this
problem
you can use the Simplex method where you
sort of uh you know intuitively start at
the corner of a polytope and walk your
way towards the bottom this is very fast
in practice in certain settings but in
theory it tends not to give the fastest
algorithms we know you can do a live
soil method where you start with some
large set that contains the minimizer
and iteratively shrink it until it
contains nothing but the minimizer these
uh tend not to outperform their worst
case theory in practice and therefore
have sort of moderate performance in
practice and some regimes have given
faster run times in theory but for
linear programming the state-of-the-art
results I'll use interior Point methods
as of now there are often the fastest in
theory and they can be very fast in
practice I want to point out that I'm
going to focus here on solving linear
programs to high accuracy so I want
methods that have like a logarithmic
dependence on Epsilon and sort of
whatever condition number measures you
might consider I'm going to hide all of
those sort of details like the these
logarithmic dependencies whenever I give
the runtimes but there is a whole line
of work on interesting first order
methods that have kind of simpler
iterates than what I'm discussing and
I'm just not going to talk about them in
this part of this talk but you can check
out Alina and diksha's talks on
optimization methods more broadly that
you know can use in some settings to
solve linear programs approximately
we're just not going to talk about them
today
all right so before I say what they are
I want to give at least one picture for
what an interior Point method looks like
just so we have something to hang on to
as I start to talk about roughly what
these different methods look like and
the obstacles that you might have to
overcome to get them to run really
efficiently
um so let me give one picture of a type
of interior Point method there's a whole
host of interior appointment meta method
literature in a variety of different
ways of running interior Point methods
and different styles this is just one
type of interior Point method that has a
particularly nice picture
uh known and it's known as path
following methods so in these path
following methods you know the way they
typically solve the linear program is
you assume that you have some nice
function P defined on the interior of
the polytope that's called a barrier
function meaning it has the property if
you go to the boundary of the polytope
the value goes to Infinity
um then a natural way to solve you know
the linear program is to consider what's
known as the penalized objective so this
is a objective function parameterized by
some parameter T that is a t multiple of
the cost plus the barrier
what you could then do is consider the
minimizers of this penalized objective
starting when T equals zero all the way
as T goes to Infinity
that set of minimizers create some curve
known as the central path you can think
in t equals zero you're just minimizing
the barrier so you're at some sort of
Center staying away from the boundary of
the polytope and as T goes to Infinity
you're trying more and more to minimize
the cost caring less and less about the
constraint and you typically converge to
a minimizer solution of the linear
program
standard template that certain types of
path methane following methods follow
you follow you apply some sort of
reduction so you can assume you start
close to the center of the polytope you
um keep following some iterative method
until you solve the problem well enough
you assume that you're at some point
close to the central path you advance
your parameter by some amount and you
take a Newton step meaning you form the
Hessian and you apply the inverse to a
gradient and you move in that direction
and you can show that based on under
nice enough assumptions of the barrier
function you know that if you can
advance long enough along the central
path and stay close enough you can solve
the problem
main takeaway to get from this is the
way I would think about linear programs
at least for the sake of this talk is
you can think it's an optimization
method that reduces linear programs to
solving linear systems so you want to
solve this linear program you define
this function everywhere in the interior
of the polytope and you keep looking at
the Hessian of it the second derivatives
and the gradient and you solve a linear
system in terms of them to figure out
where to go so the you can think it
reduces linear programming to solving
these systems provided you can access
the function well enough
all right so what's the state of the art
for linear programming let's take our
first look at just like the number of
iterations and the cost per iteration so
there was a incredible work of a
foundational work of Karma car and
renegar that showed you could ultimately
solve linear programs in root and linear
systems where the linear systems you
have to solve the computational
bottleneck they're fairly simple systems
induced by the linear program you can
think of it as like projecting onto the
projecting under the constraints under
some re-weighting of them
um and in many settings for many years
the state of the art in theory was some
variant of this root n method of renegar
but if we're solving a linear program in
D Dimensions the number of constraints
could be very very large and as the
number of constraints gets larger and
larger the method could slow down
um there are cool results of vaidya that
showed you can get a better dependence
on Dimension at the cost of solving more
linear systems and there was a beautiful
result of nestorov and nimorovski it
said you could improve the root n to a
root d if you could somehow compute
what's known as the universal barrier
it's a problem of defined in terms of
like volumes of polars and polytops and
you somehow access this you can get a
root deiteration method
um in some joint work we showed you
could get the best of both worlds you
can get a root deiteration method that
has iteration costs on comparable to
that of renegars
this led it immediately lead to some
fast algorithms but you know there's
been a lot of work on linear programming
and solving the problem more efficiently
and at least in terms of how many
iterations and coarsely if you were to
solve a linear and compute an iteration
by itself what does it cost there's been
no improvement uh you know to this slide
since
so with this how we solve linear
programs more efficiently you know if
it's you know it would be great to get
more efficient uh optimization methods
it'd be great to have less than root
deiterations this is a fantastic open
problem that's super challenging how can
we solve linear programs faster without
solving that open problem well we could
follow exactly the template I was
describing before we can think our
interior Point methods reduces our
linear program to solving a sequence of
linear systems and we could try to get
better algorithms for dynamically
solving that sequence of linear systems
and maybe the key takeaway of this part
of the talk and what I'll try to explain
is that this work that's a lot of work
that's happened on linear programming
over the last five years has developed
in two removed interior Point methods
that are improved in the sense that they
lessen the requirements or make it
easier to implement the data structure
problem of of solving the iterates
so you think there have been
improvements to the optimization method
but in terms of relaxing how much you
need to maintain in order to get the
implementing of that interior Point
method efficiently enough
and if you get it efficiently enough
there's been work you can actually solve
linear programs almost optimally
all right so what's the state of the art
um there were two results you know uh
using these two and types of interior
Point methods very broadly
um by uh carefully using that root
deiteration that method I said and using
some data structures for speeding up the
solving of the linear systems you could
get the cost per solving linear systems
and every iteration to be the the best
we would know how to do if you only
pre-process the Matrix and there was
exciting work that said
um you could solve it and end the Omega
time where Omega is the current matrix
multiplication and constant this
essentially worked by again some data
structures for solving linear systems
and robustifying essentially methods
like the one of renegar and this was a
great run this is a very nice run time
and that it matches the best known run
time just for checking feasibility of
the of the linear systems in the case
when n and D are on the same order
so these are great these were huge
improvements natural question is can we
improve further and unfortunately
neither of these run times are ever
nearly linear except when you keep
Dimension as a constant so you know and
I was highlighting everything is solving
linear programs in nearly linear or near
optimal time how can we do that
um and in a line of joint work over the
last few years we showed you could solve
linear programs in ND plus some poly D
time
and if you think your input Matrix is
dense so the number of non-zeros in The
Matrix could be at least ND and you
think that it's tall meaning you have
sufficiently enough constraints relative
to Dimension
um then ND plus poly D is just nnza
so you can think this work showed that
at least if you're in the generic case
of no sparsity structure and you have
enough constraints you can solve linear
programs in nearly linear time
and they work by combining and enhancing
the advances that underlie these results
that had to do with robustifying these
different interior Point methods to show
that it's you don't have to maintain as
much information about the iterates
um and creating a variety of different
data structures to implement them
at a very high level you know a number
of recent almost linear time algorithms
that have happened last year as are
related to this so one of these results
you know the data structures that you
would develop for linear programs you
can show are even easier to implement in
the case of solving say the maximum flow
problem or matching that led to you know
almost linear time near linear time
algorithms or Maxwell and the denses
graph and then recent exciting work you
know again used interior Point methods
for Max flow but change the type of
interior Point methods that use the sort
of L1 type of interior Point methods and
that had a big impact on the type of
data structure problem you would have to
solve at a very high level with a lot of
other insights that's what led to
maximum flow and almost linear time
what do these algorithms look like
um unfortunately I think really giving
all the details of the algorithm is
outside the scope of this sort of uh one
one hour talk
um the algebra for like what a step
looks like and what you need to maintain
is not necessarily so complicated but
the way the analysis ultimately works is
you have to show that every piece of the
algorithm everything you might need to
maintain in the linear algebra
describing the interior Point method you
can maintain it efficiently enough on
average over the life of the linear
program
um and I wanted to include this slide
not to actually call the results scary
or to make it seem too complicated or
large or unapproachable it's actually
for the opposite I'm I'm doing it
because at the end of the day the
algebra for the steps is not that
complicated the reason though some
insights and real advances happen to get
us to the understanding we're at but the
papers are rather long because even when
you have that and even when you have
like the main Insight of like why you
would expect to get the run time you
want you still have to write a data
structure for like implementing every
piece of the algorithm and every one of
these is not necessarily a sort of data
structure problem you can cite it's like
an interesting new data structure puzzle
like induced by this goal of trying to
implement these sort of interior Point
methods so they're long because you need
to have these very different pieces and
you know we can always try to do better
but we tried to you know write some of
these with some modularity that you can
read the different pieces so they're
long but because of this this structure
my opinion of the many different pieces
okay so what am I actually going to
cover what I want to cover is actually
just one of these data structure
problems I want to tell you about one
data structure problem and to me what
was like a big barrier to have any hope
of solving linear programs in near
linear time so I'm going to try to do is
convey like one of the main obstacles of
a thing you would have to do to get the
linear programs to run in near a linear
time and give you a taste of how we
overcame it and I'm going to do that
because it's going to highlight exactly
these connections between the areas that
I've been describing if you want to see
more about the various types of data
structures that you might need to
implement you should check you can check
out shinola's talk from last week if you
want to see about more about interior
Point methods in general you can check
out your news talk from next week I'm
also around for the semester if you want
to chat about any of this
okay
so what I want to try to do now is
articulate one of these like main Ops
what I think is like a key obstacle to
actually being able to get this sort of
nearly linear runtime for solving linear
programs of many constraints in the
generic case
and the issue is
fairly simple you know at the end of the
day I said it's a big open problem to
get an interior Point method that does
less than root deiterations
so whatever we do in every iteration of
the Interior Point method you know it
needs to be the case
um you know that when you multiply it by
root deer look at the cost over all of
it you know you get something that's
nearly linear
and one thing that you need to do in
these interior Point Methods at the
least as far as we know is you typically
want to maintain for your current point
just some estimate of how far it is from
every constraint
there's a lot of work on robustifying
how well you need this you only in a lot
of these methods you only need to know
the distance of the constraint
approximately you just need some crude
multiplicative estimate to it but you
need at least that
all right and what this means is you
need to run this method that's taking
root deiterations of moving this point
and what this means is you need to
maintain the distance to every single
constraint in sublinear time on average
you can't afford to do more than n root
D time on average if you're going to do
root D steps
okay so we have to move around this
large polytope keeping track of all the
different constraints and we need to do
that in less time that it would take to
actually look at every single constraint
so this creates an interesting problem
how do we compress a polytote right how
do we build a data structure to maintain
even like simpler things like the
minimum distance to every constraint
and if you think about this problem for
a little bit it's maybe not too hard to
convince yourself this is probably
impossible maybe even prove it you know
imagine you just have like a bunch of
random constraints tangent to the circle
you're at the middle and then you move
in a direction if you move in like
exactly the direction of one of the
constraints you need to know that
constraint more than any of the others
so how would you compress this
and this is I think exactly where linear
programming immediately becomes more
challenging than analogous things like
regression where we know how to
sub-sample the constraints and like
approximate the problem well enough that
we can just you know solve that like a
log number of times this is meaning we
can't really compress or throw away
completely throw away things in the same
way
all right so why would we have any hope
of solving this problem and what is this
problem so here's a simplified way of
looking at the problem you can think we
have some non-negative Vector s this is
the distance of our point to every
constraint we get some Vector Delta I
this is like the change in our Vector in
the ith iteration and we add to that
Vector s a Delta I so a Delta I is like
the change in our distance to every
constraint you can imagine we're
promised that the the
um
that this Vector s is non-negative
right so your problem is that the
distance to every uh you know that we
stay inside the polytope meaning so
that's the same as the these being
non-negative and we want to maintain
them
all right so we just have this Vector a
we keep adding a Delta one a Delta 2 a
Delta 3. we want to maintain this
multiplicatively promised it's not
negative
okay
as I just argued this seems impossible
but there's a important classic
observation in tier Point methods this
is what I uh like things like this is
what underlied even uh you know uh Karma
cars method solving linear programs more
efficiently we know that on average the
changes in these differences they're
small on average if you look at the L2
Norm of the changes the multiplicative
changes in the constraint in karma in
renegar style methods it's O of one in
our method it's root ND and you can do
the analysis on it it essentially says
something like every root D iterations
they're only n coordinates that change
by a constant so as you move through the
polytope yes you can get closer to any
constraint but if you get too close to
one constraint it's probably the only
constraint whose distance is changing so
there's this bound on the total amount
of changes in the constraints
right and the fact that every root
deiterations their only n multiplicative
changes in your distances means that if
you can just detect when a distance to a
constraint changes by a constant in O of
D time which is the cost of just looking
at that constraint then you could get an
ND method in principle you can over you
have to overcome this you use the phrase
every time that you are changing your
position the distance is changing all of
them yeah
yeah because you say that phrase that
every time the distances are changing if
you are close to the constraint the
minimizer is
what do you mean I just mean if we're in
the polytope and we move the point not
many of the constraints will probably
change by a little bit we did a random
change they would all change by
something just some more than others
um all right so with this observation
that we have like a bound on the total
change
um let me discuss that more at the end
if it doesn't become clear
um you know let me say our actual result
we give a data structure that can solve
the problem over T iterations where the
cost of maintaining these multiplicative
distances it depends by the total you
know rescaled L2 Norm change and this is
something so that if you work it out
this becomes ND in the particular case
of linear programs
so I want to give a sense of how you
could hope to solve this problem I
already think this is interesting like
this thing of trying to maintain
multiplicative distances to the
constraints under L2 movements at least
myself I don't know if I would have
promoted that as a data structure
problem just by itself but given this
role that it has insight into your
appointment is a very natural problem to
look at
all right
um uh I just want to give a quick sense
of how this how our solution to this
works so the idea here is we can take
our Matrix a so here's a warm-up problem
that essentially once you see the
solution to you can get the more General
solution so our warm-up problem is we
just have our Matrix a and suppose we
just take our movement Vector Delta and
suppose it's small in L2 Norm it's at
most one
there's only one coordinate now that can
change by a constant additively
find it you know ofd time so we
pre-process our Matrix we have a small
change find the one coordinate that
changed this is like the version of this
problem when you start with the
distances being one so your distance to
every constraint is one and then you
like make a small movement
all right how do you solve this problem
this problem is essentially the question
of like how do you sketch a matrix so
you find like large entries in the
associated Vector when you multiply it
with another right
now hopefully all of you that were in
boot camp last week recognize this
problem
um and we're paying attention and
Michael's wonderful talk because Michael
essentially showed us how to solve this
problem you can take things like count
sketch matrices and it's known that if
you take if you you know to pick
appropriate projections you can come up
with these matrices that are have one
over Epsilon squared rows that are very
fast to compute that if you multiply
them with any Vector you can find all
the coordinates that have more than a
constant fraction of the L2 Norm of the
vector
okay so if all you do is pre-process
your Matrix a by applying one of these
projection matrices to it so collapsing
the number of rows from n to some
constant and then applying that sketch
to the vector X you know applying the
recovery you'll find the large
coordinates
so you kind of sketch the whole Matrix
you can find the large coordinates
if you want to solve a slightly harder
problem so you're given now you want to
pre-process your Matrix and you're given
some direction you move in and you want
to Output all the coordinates that
change by a constant and time
proportional to the movement well you
could simply apply your sketch at every
level of different accuracy that's a
power of two
use a sketch to estimate this L2 Norm to
know which sketch to look at and then
look at that sketch and that sketch will
recover all of them you can check it has
the right runtime scaling
going a bit quick so I want to make sure
to say something about matching before I
run out of time
um but you know it's with a bit more
work you can see show that just
carefully applying this warm-up result
to different powers of two and like
updating things when they change you can
you know divide up the you can apply
this problem in like different time
intervals at different time scales and
eventually gives you this runtime
foreign
there's a big problem here though so
there's like a big reason that
unfortunately this this creates a a big
obstacle and I hope that it's ringing
some alarm bells for for some people in
the audience
and the alarm Bell goes back to exactly
what I was saying is one of the major
difficulties that some of these almost
linear time algorithms have to overcome
to get fast algorithms
you know the problem is this sketch this
projection to find large coordinates it
only works if the randomness of the
sketch is independent of the thing being
sketched
well we're going to use this sketch to
inform the next iteration of the
Interior Point method and to form the
next thing that you run the algorithm on
right so and to get this runtime we need
to reuse the sketch it's expensive to
apply the sketch to The Matrix we don't
want to do it every iteration we want to
just do it once and reuse it forever
so how do you get around this here
there's a nice trick you can do it falls
into I I highly recommend looking at
vegetables talk on graph data structures
I know this is not a graph problem as I
post it but gave a nice uh argument of
the different sorts of ways you can try
to handle this adaptive adversary issue
where the input could depend on the
output in the the previous layer
uh you can use a kind of natural
technique here if you think what we want
to use the data structure for we just
want to use it to detect all the
constraints that change by at least some
threshold
and we can afford to check not just the
ones that change at that threshold but
also a larger threshold
right so what we could do is just detect
all of them at a larger threshold
and then for everyone that we think
Changed by something we could look at
the Matrix and check the exact amount it
actually changed by
and we could give make that the output
the data structure only if it meets that
exact amount
and with this we can say that what our
data structure outputs with high
probability doesn't depend on the
randomness we are exactly outputting
every coordinate that it changed by a
fixed threshold
with that you can use things over and
over again
all right before moving on and so you
guys want to say a few words about
matching before we run out of time I
just want to give like a quick diagram
to what what just happened here you know
we took our linear program I said you
could apply this into your point methods
to reduce it to solving a sequence of
linear systems that solving the liquids
of linear systems or maintaining the
information we need in the linear
program we could use sketching to at
least check when all the constraints any
constraints change by too much among a
number of other data structures
before make moving on I want to make a
few broad points about this one we are
using sketching the construct uh project
the constraints and collapse things but
as I said you can't you can't uh you
know in general it seems like actually
like sample away or sparsify or reduce
the size of the linear program
instead what we're doing here we're not
as happens in a number of other
optimization algorithms you know taking
your linear program or taking your
problem and saying that there's a sparse
approximate version of it you can solve
instead we're saying you can sketch it
at different scales and maintain the
information about it you need over time
sort of a type of dynamic access to
we're giving getting a sort of dynamic
access to the problem rather than just
kind of reducing on a static thing that
seems to contain enough information
um and Beyond another thing I want to
say is beyond that this led to some more
efficient algorithms you know this whole
line of work I hope this highlights how
thinking of the interplay of these
pieces you know it leads to different
ways of thinking about why an
optimization method is efficient and you
know motivates different types of data
structure and sketching problems
it's not all I want to say about linear
programming
at like 10 minutes left
more or less
I guess I will take questions now does
anyone have a question
let's try and use the mic
all right let's say a few words about
Dynamic matching and then all right
so
so in this next I want to switch gears
and as I said so this was like one
example of this template of reducing
solving um you know a certain static
problem linear programming to a certain
number of dynamic problems I want to
give an interesting application of going
in reverse
so I'm going to do here is consider a
natural Dynamic problem this is a really
well studied foundational uh broad class
of dynamic graph problems we'll consider
the problem of dynamic matching
so in this problem we're assume we're
given some bipartite graph we're given
some n vertices and some M edges what we
want to do is output an Epsilon
approximate matching
so we call something a matching if it's
a subset of the edges such that no
vertex is incident to more than one Edge
we call it one minus Epsilon approximate
if the number of edges we include is at
least a one minus Epsilon fraction of
the most we could include what's known
as the maximum matching
what we want to do is maintain
um a maximum matching under Edge
deletions there's a variety of different
variants of this problem that are
considered we're just going to focus on
this very specific one where we're given
the whole graph we can see the whole
graph and then edges are deleted until
the graph is gone
and what we want is after every single
deletion to have maintained an
approximate maximum matching right this
is known as a decremental dynamic
bipartite matching the decremental
because of edge deletions
right
um and there's prior a lot of Prior work
on Dynamic matching in general there's a
result that solves the more General
problem of additions and deletions with
a root depend square root dependence on
the number of edges and some poly
dependence on the desired accuracy
um but that's actually prior to some
work I'll tell you about the state of
the art for solving this problem there's
a lot more results known if you change
the model so if you're instead
considering Edge additions or if you
want constant approximation like you
don't need to work for all Epsilon or if
your updates are entire vertices and
everything adjacent to it rather than
these Edge updates there's all sorts of
algorithms in those different settings
if you want to see more about this
broader literature and dynamic graph
algorithms you can look to the past to
Thatcher Paul's talk on graph data
structures or to the Future to Monaco's
talk next week
all right so how do we solve this even
more quickly and how do we make good on
the thing I said of like how can we use
optimization Theory or anything like uh
static optimization algorithms to speed
up the solving of this very natural
Dynamic problem we need to maintain a
matching every time something's deleted
well to start we can use that there's a
nice known reduction that you don't have
to maintain a maximum matching it
suffice us to be able to just maintain
fractional matchings it's enough to
maintain convex combinations of matching
the set are large enough so we call a
real value assignment to the edges of
the graph a fractional matching if it's
not negative and no vertex has more than
one unit of value assigned on the edges
adjacent to it
call it Epsilon approximate if the sum
of those values is at least one minus
Epsilon of the max matching size and
there's a line of work on giving
efficient reductions from maintaining
Dynamic matchings to maintaining Dynamic
fractional matchings I would think a
fractional matchings as convex
combinations of matchings and you know
their size being large enough says
something about the average size of the
matchings in some decomposition
all right
so what's the idea this was a cool idea
done in some uh recent work of
um
and the idea was the following here's
like a natural simple template like if I
told you our goal is to kind of reduce
this Dynamic problem just to solving
static problems what might you do well
you would compute to fractional matching
okay so let's try to follow a simple
template that has maybe any hope of
solving the problem we'll compute some 1
minus Epsilon fractional matching and
what we'll do is even when deletions
come even when edges are removed we'll
just remove them from our fractional
matching two so we have our fractional
matching if an edge is deleted we have
some value of it we set that value to
zero because we're not allowed to use
that edge
and what we'll do is we'll just keep
using that fractional matching until you
know Epsilon times its size amount of
values on the edges have been deleted
it's pretty easy to check that this will
always maintain a 1 minus o of Epsilon
matching you know as Epsilon approximate
it was you know its value was one minus
Epsilon I've opt right and we recomputed
with only like Epsilon optimount of
stuff was deleted so you have to be a
little careful multiplicative but you
get a 1 minus o of Epsilon fractional
matching
so this algorithm clearly maintains an
Epsilon approximate fractional matching
the two natural questions are well what
fractional matching should you pick and
can you actually show you don't need to
recompute it or you can get away with
recomputing it so if infrequently that
this actually leads to a fast algorithm
foreign
and interesting in that work they showed
this broad template does work
um you can find you can compute a
certain fractional matchings fast enough
and bound their stability show you can
use them for so long that you can
decrease the the amount of cost of uh
maintaining this matching under
deletions to an amortize something that
only depends logarithmically on the size
of the graph and polynomially on the
accuracy
what I'm going to do is tell you about
some recent joint work we had that I
think got this type of result through a
kind of net uh I think a clear like
makes it clear the optimization
connection sort of underlying this
all right and I think does this in a way
you know the analysis not paper the the
algorithm for computing the matching
um and the analysis of why it's stable
you don't recompute uh you know was had
a bit to it
um I'll discuss a simple way that kind
of cleanly decouples these two things
kind of decouples how you compute this
fractional matching or any uh from the
the fact that you can get efficient out
like you don't have to recompute it too
often
so here's the idea we'll do a thing
that's very natural in optimization
Theory let's consider the problem of
just maximizing over something like
fractional matchings so we'll maximize
over non-negative vectors the sum of the
um the the values of of the entries of
that Vector plus some some function r
that I'll call A regularizer all right
and this regularizer is going to serve
two roles it's going to insert something
so that from the solution of this we can
quickly deduce a one minus Epsilon
approximate matching and it will somehow
assume that we don't you know
concentrate on just one matching when
there may be many matchings like on a
nice motivating example in the other
papers on the complete graph you want to
spread uh the fractional matching is to
put the values uniformly over all the
edges rather than picking one matching
which might be brittle and you would
have to recompute after a few updates
all right
um and we show that there's a variety of
different ways you can pick this R such
that using the optimality conditions for
solving this problem you can show that
you only need to recompute one over
Epsilon squared times
essentially the argument is you can show
that you can pick certain values of R so
that on average you know essentially the
objective decreases by a multiplicative
one minus Epsilon squared every time a
deletion happens when every time you
would have to recompute and since
there's a range of the value you don't
recompute that many times
all right and these functions that we
picked are not in my opinion that uh
esoteric you can do a natural thing
where you just set the value of R to be
some scaling of entropy a natural thing
which would encourage the value to be
spread out over all the edges
and we Define it to be entropy for
everything that is a fractional matching
and infinity if you're not to matching
so you compute the minimum entry
fractional the sorry you compute the
minimum combination of value and entropy
fractional matching
okay
and you can show that if you pick that
something like that as the regularizer
you only need to recompute one over
Epsilon squared times
I answer this at the beginning of the
talk I'll check your all paying
attention how do you solve this problem
so this is great I can say that this is
a nice way of proof and the analysis of
this is rather short I think from the
optimality conditions of entropy
all right but that's all and well and
good but how do we solve this problem of
you know Max entropy matching you know
over Max
combination of entropy and size matching
over the matching polytope
sounds related to Interior Point good
what was the other the other uh
try to use sketching that's interesting
happy to talk after the talk any other
any other any other attempts
or thoughts thoughts
you can you can use the max flow
algorithms so it turns out if you
manipulate things a little bit things
like this you can actually reduce to the
the maximum flow of a result of selling
Maxwell and most of your time solves a
broader class of sort of uh
flow optimization problems and you can
put this one into that framework so you
can compute this to high accuracy and
then to the one plus the world one time
and if you do this if you feed it if you
do this this then just gives you an O of
Epsilon squared advertised per deletion
algorithm for computing fractional
matchings
and in some recent joint work we then um
you know I said there were these
efficient reductions from I mentioned
there was either official reductions
from Computing a maximum a fractional
Dynamic fractional matching to maximum
matching Unfortunately they had like a
cost that was a high enough polyepsilon
that it would have been the barrier here
but some recent joint work we showed you
can speed that up too using a variety of
things so you can get an amortized one
over Epsilon squared per dilution for
maintaining an integer maximum
and even full hats so so how is this
cool terminology if you're hiding the
little n to the little of one factor as
opposed to this polyline
I'm glad people are paying attention
yeah
great questions
um uh I should point out this is some
interesting work on solving these
problems more efficiently there's a lot
much broader line of work on Dynamic
graph algorithms more broadly that I
gave those references to before there's
also work on showing hardness for
solving a variety of dynamic graph
problems and you can check out the talk
of scenes on on that last week and with
that I think I've referenced every
Workshop talk from last week
with that I guess I'll I'll wrap up
um this is just a taste of some of I
think the many surprising Rich
connections I just want to say there's a
much broader line of work here like
rather in this getting solving Dynamic
algorithms more efficiently as
thatchapal talked about last week
There's work on solving Dynamic
algorithm solving Dynamic problems more
efficiently by taking the static
algorithms and trying to more directly
dynamize the optimization method itself
and there's work of doing that both for
Max flow and for linear programs even in
the iterative methods these methods I
said I wasn't talking about before for
solving optimization problems
approximately like zero-sum games you
can play games with the optimization
methods and data structures for
implementing them you know to solve
these problems faster both classically
and quantumly and even on problems that
don't seem to have quite as much
structure like minimize a convex
function with a subgradient Oracle you
know there's some interesting work on
how to build the right sort of data
structures so that you can get parallel
algorithms for them and I'm happy to
take questions on these or talk talk
about any of them later but I just
wanted to this has some privacy
implications want to point out that that
it's not contained to linear program and
its special case of Maximum flow
um moving forward I think this is an
incredibly Rich space all these tools
and techniques they're promoting
different problems to look at in
different ways and I think rapidly a lot
of new tools and problems are being
created and the short if you take
nothing else in the talk I think it's an
exciting semester and some years ahead
for this area so thank you
[Applause]
thank you
questions
for dynamic
for dynamic matching I know there's like
a lot of also combinatorial algorithms
and there's a lot of different versions
of the problems like how good your
approximation is and all this kind of
thing so I was wondering if there are
um like if you can specify like which
regimes are are good for like this type
of optimization stuff in which resumes
like use the other types of techniques
yeah it's a it's a it's a good question
so so repeat broadly I guess questions
like what regimes are amenable to these
optimization methods or not like when
when can we use this machinery
it's a great question I I the short
answer is I don't know I guess we've
been pushing some of the optimization
methods I guess a number of people here
have been doing great work on showing
conditional hardnesses in a bunch of
cases I think it's an exciting thing
it's of the many reasons there was a
conditional hardness talk
um last week it's an exciting thing that
maybe some of these we can hope to you
know improve from both sides and come up
with a tight characterization for when
to do this but I it's a great question
I'd be happy to discuss more but at the
top of my head I don't know if I have
the right
uh you know like test of like ah this is
a thing that we should be able to obtain
for this at least for dynamizing these
sorts of problems that we have convex
optimization tools
um
that work I mentioned maybe just as to
say a surprise this work I mentioned
so I'll give a fun anecdote more to
convey my uncertainty about the the
answer to that question so in this work
on Dynamic Max flow so we gave this work
on solving if our call currently
incremental Max flow and capacitated
graphs
um and there's certain conditional
hardness in certain regimes if you were
able to solve the problem too precisely
um and when in in too good an amortized
update time
and this paper we showed you could do
something that might seem a little
surprising we said what you can do to
high accuracy is not you know exactly
maintain the max flow uh the max flow in
this graph but you can exactly know the
time at which the max flow value crosses
a threshold
which I think was kind of cool when we
figured out I'm not entirely sure I
would have guessed it in hindsight it
makes sense has having done all the
analysis
um so I think it's a great question I
think it's interesting question even
figure out how to answer that question
so thank you
even all these advances in algorithmics
uh I I want to uh
probe a little bit about the Practical
implications and uh so I guess
when we have a lot of polylogs piled on
that can yeah uh really hurt things if
if the run time is is predicted by the
uh by the worst case run time so I guess
I'm asking you to
uh speculate or or or or or or make some
observations about
whether these algorithms or maybe their
descendants in uh future versions of
them uh could run quickly made maybe the
uh is the worst case analysis a little
pessimistic or are these the kinds of
algorithms that are going to really hit
their worst case behavior all the time
so that's a great question
um my answer is going to be another
long-winded I'm not sure but I'm glad
you're both participants in the program
um I I think it's a great question I
think a lot of this definitely there's a
lot of work for the proof of concept
that you can solve these problems in
almost linear time we haven't had them
for that long so how much you can polish
each piece which ones you'd actually
want to implement versus which ones are
just not an issue in practice you know a
lot of this work of handling adaptive
adversaries we could have an interesting
discussion about where that arises and
there's a number of interesting
trade-offs here so on the more negative
side I will say this thing I said about
um you know you get these wins from more
iterations in practice more iterations
could be a big issue regardless of the
implementation if you want to implement
things in parallel or if you're you know
one of the many reasons to my
understanding interior Point methods
have been so impactful and as you and
you commented on is because yes we don't
know how to prove better than root
deiteration methods but in practice they
go many few iterations
I think though that these problems are
at least elucidating the sort of
structure that you can hang on to sue to
solve the problem more efficiently I
hope it creates something so I'm a
little do I'm a little scared to
speculate about exactly the limits of
all of this especially with the early
days
but it's a great question
yes
like oh inspired by the question I would
like to understand so
for the Simplex we know that it is
in theory but at least there was like a
bunch of words that they try to say in
the smooth analysis complexity something
good is happening so ipms are super
methods yes we like them
if we really use them in practice I was
wondering we shouldn't be able to give
an average case analysis that says oh
you know actually even the worst case
that you that we claim is not something
that is happening it happens in the main
case something even better so I think
that's a great question
um I think it's if I understood
correctly connected to I think what I
was trying to say before which is not
clear which of
which piece is something we really need
to do to make everything work out
algorithmically and without that we
don't have enough structure versus we're
doing it because to really handle the
worst case that we never encounter uh
we're doing it and I think it's just
early to figure out
or a little outside at least the scope
of the talk I'm giving today to figure
out which is which I do want to give one
other just just clarification point from
something you said I tried to use my
words carefully I hope I got it right so
so the state-of-the-art linear
programming methods are not Simplex but
there are randomized polynomial times
Simplex methods even without this even
without the smooth analysis which was a
a big advancement of my advisor and his
so I believe that's a result of um yeah
um so so so so so the story The is a the
picture is a
even a little more rich in some places
yeah
I'm in I'm a bit of an outsider I have a
question perhaps to the to the community
uh do you know I mean this is all again
inspired by the previous discussion that
these instances that you get in practice
are often like efficiently solvable
um is the community looking at the kind
of structure that you have in Practical
instances and trying to characterize
this and and does this lead to
uh yeah so I think that's a great
question and a good one to explore I'm
not going to try to speak for the whole
Community here I think I guess your
question I think there are interesting
questions about smooth analysis and
different sorts of uh things you could
you could you could uh
you could do
um on this broad line I'm not directly
answering your question I want to point
out one interesting thing about this
thing of computing like entropy
regularized matchings that potentially
has interesting appeal for different
reasons than just computational ones I I
actually find this result interesting
just the mirror fact you can specify the
existence of these objects right way I
think that I can use them we can use
them to solve decremental matching
faster is like one way of highlighting
why it's interesting but I'm not sure
that's the only or even the best but I
completely dodged your question which is
a great one that happy to discuss after
or encourage you to discuss
I mean in a lot of sense when the
complexity is not just like they're
non-zero bike
I'm just asking your questions like
every time that we give a result instead
of saying n times D we say that it is
almost nearby the non-zero wives of the
and automatics it's a measure of the
structure of the problem like house
Parts it is
well no there is more than sparsity yeah
yeah right yeah
great questions
I still want to make sure I wasn't
painting the Simplex Methodist
[Applause]